(typing)
- [Nathan] The video
hadn't even been uploaded,
and I was already getting
worried about people
revealing the secret,
plus watching the video again,
I started to doubt that
this would fool anyone.
- [Man] Goat in the water.
- All I could do at this point
was upload the video,
and let the public decide.
- [Man] Goat in the water.
(dramatic music)
- [Nathan] When I woke
up the next morning,
I was astounded to see
the video had been posted
on Gawker, eBaum's World, and
a Body Building message board.
It had over 3,000 views
and that was way more
then I ever expected.
Then I saw it was climbing
the charts on Reddit.
Then I checked the view
count an hour later.
Holy Shit.
- By the way, this may
sound like a sea rescue,
but a goat, a baby goat
gets stuck in water.
- This is some pig.
You have to see it.
A goat at a petting zoo
got stuck in a lake.
- [Girl] This really happened.
- [Woman] That was cool.
- Have no fear, there's a pig there.
I mean, you couldn't do
this at Warner Brothers.
As a cartoon, it would make it seem
more realistic.
- Where we were duty-bound
to pass this on.
It's the leading web video today.
While we have no way of knowing
if it's real, this was apparently shot
at a petting zoo.
That's a baby goat who got
out into too deep water,
begins crying for help.
Enter this pig.
(woman speaks in a foreign language)
(cartoon in a foreign language)
- [Nathan] It seemed like the whole world
was talking about my video.
For a moment, I felt bad
because it wasn't real,
but then I realized,
that that didn't matter.
- Enter species.
He wouldn't help.
Learn from it, humans.
- [Nathan] In these cynical times,
people are desparate for
something to believe in
and I gave people a reminder
that it's okay just to believe.
- How did the pig free the goat?
(chattering)
(laughs)
- Every day with Elizabeth it's like,
"How did this happen?"
- [Nathan] I always knew this
video was something special
and that's why in the end,
I decided not to put the name
of the petting zoo on it.
I didn't want it to
come across like an ad,
you know, for the petting zoo.
- Right.
- I'd rather be a bit transparent, so.
- But of people would've known that it was
Oak Tree Village (mumbles).
- But I mean, you can be so selfish.
- Selfish?
- Well, I mean people love the video.
It's like, it can't just
be all about the business.
- But that's it was supposed to be,
about when you first came up,
it was supposed to be about the business.
- [Nathan] Terry just
didn't seem to understand
but I don't leave those
that I help empty-handed.
That's why I made her this sign.